mess that up i'm here with the danielle
radford and the lawn harris
uh we're gonna watch the trailer
together you'll get our behind the
scenes thoughts and feelings about it
uh we're gonna respond to comments and
questions from viewers like yourselves
we'll see some deleted scenes
we'll tease next week's on his trailer
it's a nice little show we got going
here um
and let's talk about a nice little show
that marvel had going there the falcon
and the winter soldier
uh i don't have too much to say
ahead of time like in a broad sense
because it's like
i enjoyed it it was uh it felt like we
said in the trailer like a b-tier marvel
movie that got split into six parts
um i think a little it's like a quality
parabola
like it starts off slow where you're
like what is this
and then it ends on this kind of off
note but the middle was great like i
i really enjoyed it's it's it's weird
usually you think of shows like opening
grade or closing grade and then
it's like a bird or something when it's
like time for fun and games and they're
all like going around magical
and they're and they're they're raising
all these very interesting questions and
they're discovering all these very
intriguing
plot threads to pull and that just kind
of peters out at the end that's
that's my that's
i thought dynamite it's one two and six
that are the trouble
yeah what's it gonna end in the no you
just gotta end on the gunshots like
that's no i completely agree like i
really liked the questions
that we were getting i just don't know
that uh speechifying solves all problems
uh
i feel like we've tried that a couple
times and problems are still here
so the west wing caused a lot of nerds
to go into politics
and fast talking and walking yeah so
maybe this will cause a lot of people to
go into
vigilantism i don't know what they are
at this point um
but um like worked for he's with the
government like
i guess so but he's like freelance it's
like oh you're working with the air
force now
but he was he was definitely in the air
force when we met him
he was in the airport and he broke like
he went off the grid and like he fled
justice when he went with cap uh
so he was gone for a while but then post
he's like back in i guess he must have
lost his pension but that that
takes us to the whole to the whole month
we'll get into that i'm sure we all have
thoughts on um
something i just wanted to respond to
that people are uh
appear to be piling on right at the
beginning is like how dare you accuse me
of not caring about
uh bucky before this thing and i've just
never understood
that i know it i'm sorry because i know
it exists
i knew it like back in uh in winter
soldier and throughout but like
they are just much like wanda envisioned
for me it's like people are building
so much investing so much and play so
much currency in these relationships
that have gotten
20 minutes of screen time across the 21
movies or something like that 30 minutes
it's
generous they're good at doing this but
it's what they're yeah they're like
subtly giving you like a sense of what
this relationship is from just like a
shared moment or two like bucky and sam
had very little screen time together
yeah i remember them nodding in the car
like right good job uh cap and stuff and
i knew they were
friends friend of mish is but they were
both like there was a triangle with them
and steve
but beyond that like i can't maybe this
is just me or maybe i'm the
i don't know maybe i'm in the minority i
didn't really care about bucky
on a deeper level until this show that's
that that's my point of view what do you
guys say
i think for me it was his time in
wakanda like that was when i was like
yeah
i get a white wolf um i think that that
was when i became more interested in
bucky
um but the fan fiction y'all yeah the
fan fiction
huge deep you know uh relationships
i gotta get back onto uh what where is
it these days is it wattpad or
where are the kids slashing it up i
think it's the a03 is where the splashes
okay
uh yeah i mean i i guess i'm sort of
more with you like i i
i recall like a lot of our jokes in the
honest trailer writer's room or whatever
even going back to like civil war was so
much of the plot of the mcu revolves
around bucky like
he's the wedge that drives iron man and
captain america apart
pushing that whole big storyline forward
and yet we really didn't ever get to
know him that well as a guy
who was always like bucky is steve's
friend
going back to the first movie and we're
invested in it because of the history as
opposed to because like
what we we know and love bucky um
but i i guess again i'm sort of with you
on that the fans kind of took it and ran
with it and and had their own
head cannon that they really enjoyed
around and look sebastian sant's a very
good actor
doing a lot with not that much like i
get it but um
yeah this was the first time i felt like
we really got to know sam
and bucky as characters as opposed to
the falcon you know like the guy with
the jetpack who's steve's friend
yep yeah agreed uh and yeah definitely
falcon obviously
i mean uh uh the falcon it's not a
filmmaker that's why you gotta put the
the
he's not sam falcon wilson he's
he's the falcon uh i was going to call
him a lovable loser
uh and i i mean that in only the most
literal way and that as we point out in
a deleted scene he's lost like every
major fight he's ever been
like he's just been kind of like the guy
you fight to prove that
okay this person's serious and we should
we sh we mean business
um but we'll get to that at the end
let's in the deleted scenes let's do
uh our honest trailer for the falcon and
the winter soldier
from the streaming service with the
biggest gap between quality of content
and suckage of interface comes marvel's
latest avengers you didn't really care
about
until they got their own tv show the
falcon and the winter soldier
who's next hawkeye of course
i think hawkeye just reading the tea
leaves is going to immediately be like
we need a new hawkeye
jeremy renner's like here take this bow
and then he backflips out of the frame
but i mean it's it is sort of him
passing
yeah yeah yeah bishop yeah yeah
right um i'm just say i'm just thinking
that hawkeye will not be
uh long for that series i don't think
they're gonna kill him off but i think
it's
it's even though it's his name or his
moniker
he's not going to keep it for very long
yeah i mean i'm not a marvel comics
reader in in a way that i've gotten to
know hawkeye that way and he's one of
those characters where you kind of make
fun of him from the movies and people
like
oh he's so great in the comics it's a
shame we can't so
maybe this will finally be the
opportunity to get the hawkeye that has
made so many fans
of the comics onto the big screen at
last because so far it just kind of
seems like
he's kind of a non-starter in a lot of
ways in the fridge
all right keep going when a rogue super
soldier is on the loose
the only thing that can stop her is a
few shots from a regular gun
but since the story as the last six
episodes two of marvel's weakest heroes
are on the case sam the falcon wilson
a man with the power of a jet pack he
rents from the air force
and bucky the winter soldier barnes
proof that men will literally scour the
criminal safe haven of madrid
instead of going to therapy you missed
your court mandated therapy
sorry mr barnes you're under arrest but
when these not even that opposite
military guys have to work together
you'll be in for a lot of forced
bickering that's not a thing that
doesn't
cause i don't want to put this in the
same breath
as something like men in black
international
but i feel like wow they didn't do
they didn't do to me sharply enough
to find the buddy cop dynamic which is
ones of this and one's of that like when
they're both
fairly serious military dudes who like
both love steve rogers
and yes the winter soldier's going like
a little off the books but the first
time we meet
uh uh falcon it's like you're you're
invading libyan airspace like
he doesn't really care he's kind of
freelancing taking down
you know drug kingpins and stuff like
that i don't know i just uh
to me it just didn't feel like you had
enough of a difference between the two
of them to make that
dynamic like super understandable and
yeah go ahead danielle do they remind
themselves of each other too much is
that why they don't like it
i just think we never really got past
that like move your
move your seat seat and i feel like
everything kind of expands from that
and i don't know if they ever did a
really good you know in this obviously
they do when they expand their
relationship
and now bucky is invited to the barbecue
um
too many people invited to that barbecue
but that's fine we're just
giving out invitations left and ryan
aren't we um but yeah so
but but in the beginning that's really
all it is it's still that like animosity
over like
i'm steve's friend and you're steve's
friend but i'm not your friend
we're not friends um and i feel like
that's
a weird thing to start a relationship on
is like
uh both of our buddies left us and now
we're like the two exes left behind
and they never really moved past that
for like a while during this yeah we
need more of like a murtaugh and rigs or
like a like a wolverine and cyclops
like very clear who's
which type of guy to understand why they
instantly don't like each other so much
i think i think danielle sort of hit it
on the head like this is the thing i
i tweeted during the first episode of
this that i think people yelled at me
about um
but uh i i feel like a lot of the
current
phase of marvel that we're in has still
been about the legacy of these
characters that we said goodbye to
last time and like i get that you gotta
do some of that i'm not saying
none of that but it's it's time like
like this show is now i feel like the
point where it's like i'm tired of
everybody being weepy about their friend
who's gone
and i will we might as well add it down
uh
did not do a good job of letting us know
where
steve is and what's going on with it
they tried to be kind of coy about it
like
maybe he's dead maybe he's just uh
space now you don't know and like
i might not know but sam and bucky would
know he wouldn't just be like yeah
i wonder if they're intentionally i'm
sure that is leaving the door open for
future
[Music]
phases
like the assumption is that he did they
were treating him like he was dead or
that they were keeping his what
remaining short life he has left a
secret
because sam would have like called him
but like what do you think i like put
down the werther's original for a second
and help me out what should i do
about the flag smashers i i think these
they want us to think uh he's dead until
until shown otherwise until they uh uh
panic
and bring back uh but that's something
that's gonna be like i feel like the
time
that we could have maybe spent figuring
out who these guys were in relation to
one another and where their
where their clash where their conflicts
lie
and what the sorts of their bickering
might be was instead spent on them
worrying about steve's legacy and what
about
what how would steve do this and it's
just like okay i feel like we did that
moment and now i'm ready to
move on i just want to see the next uh
tv series be like two guys arguing over
who gets to wear hulk's ripped pants
a lot to wear the pants i look better in
purple
should we delete thor and cork's
fortnite accounts or will they be back
and want to play these characters again
right keep going no it's not a lot of
forced quips
now that falcon is technically the funny
one and he mastered posing stoic
and so much forced talk about cap's old
shield that you'll start to wish cap was
short for please decapitate me
thank you captain america but this
belongs to you
let's take the shield and do this
ourselves you got to give me the shield
man
he gave you that shield for a reason
why'd you give up that shield he had no
right to give up the shield sam
shouldn't have given him the shield
i didn't give him the shield that
shield's the closest thing i've got left
to a family
it's just a shield bro don't lose your
arm over it
you know you think you would know that
there's a button that pops his arm off i
mean doesn't even play with that thing
return to the military espionage side of
the mcu
where the morals are as gray as the
visuals full of shady characters
like semo a fancy dancer
who talks about the black experience one
too many times for someone who blew up
the king of wakanda
i told him about trouble man he wrote i
mean i don't
mind this because i like who zemo has
become but wow what a
what a what a glow up i don't know what
happened but between civil war and this
one but he just
he really seemed like he was working
alone and he wasn't like a billionaire
with his own alfred
and like uh just a dude who like a euro
trash batman
they really flipped the script on us i
i'm not mad because i prefer this
version
but uh where did that come from just the
yeah just the comics like someone
remembered like oh we have this comic
and like this character and we can do
something interesting with him isn't he
like
got a lot of money and then they
remember that he was a baron and it's
not just like his first name and they
can
they can make him euro trash batman
which i agree with you i think is a much
more interesting
i would much rather like the the baron
zemo that's constantly escaping stuff
and just wants to hang out and party uh
this is my favorite
like obviously it's just so different
from the guy who's like my family who
killed my family i've been obsessed
with revenge on my food he's introduced
explicitly as like
they do the badass credential thing with
him it's like
special forces he did 18 tours you know
like it was that
and it's that that he's in like the camo
with the gun you know like it was that
thing
and i i like i don't mean to go back in
like second guess like obviously those
years ago was a totally different moment
in the franchise
but like it doesn't really make sense
that you'd go with such a generic
backstory when you also had
he's a bear like there's no reason that
couldn't have worked and it would have
just been so much more interesting
i guess they felt like they just needed
to like move move move we don't have
time
i mean if you had like a a a funky
techno
dance break in the middle of the winter
soldier it would have been a little
jarring i think
yeah okay you could put a you could put
a funky disco dance break in there i
could do it in queens
they had so many other things they had
to like service
in civil war like that's what i'm saying
like i you know all of these movies are
a puzzle of like
well we gotta service this thing to go
here or this to go here so like
i get that that zemo was an opportunity
to like
you know shorthand this thing and we'll
move through it quickly but
this is so much i love being serviced as
a fan i gotta say
i'm serviced what these movies do is
they go you know they got four other
projects they have to like tee up
while they're telling you the story yeah
all right let's keep going
it is a masterpiece james it captures
the african-american experience
sharon carter who's grown bitter and
resentful since the man she stalked for
a living went back in time to bang her
great aunt
and john walker the heir apparent to the
kool-aid guy
oh yeah he may look the part but this
blond-haired honk still isn't ready to
take on the mantle of america's next
kurt russell
also julie louie dreyfus pops up at the
end because everyone in hollywood is
obligated
to join the mcu at this point your next
costanza this whole
universe is against me promise to kevin
for uh
i think kevin no one will escape the
fury of the flag smashers
a movement with a nefarious plan to
deliver food and medicine to refugees
but don't worry they'll kill just enough
people to qualify as villains
i agree known as pulling the killman i
just can't give it the way you're
fighting
you tell him falcon she needs to join
the military first that's the mcu's
license to kill
to combat his rising threat of poor
people having nowhere to live
sam must become a new kind of captain
america
one who will call out the problem do you
guys like the suit
no right okay just checking i'm i'm good
with
everything neck down i think neck down
i'm fine it's the it's the like
goggle visor first of all it just looks
uncomfortable and weird like wearing a
sleeve around your face but
it's also just a it's just weird and it
especially him delivering like that very
impassioned sorkini speech to the
senators
wearing this headgear was just like at
least take the
take the guy i mean i didn't realize you
know like it's it's not as bad as
as seeing batman during the day but i
didn't realize that captain america
when you became captain america you
basically just had to like put the suit
on
even if you were just like walking
around asking people questions like john
walker is just like walking through
europe dressed as captain america how
are you doing
yeah i would totally assume that that
was you know like a guy on hollywood
boulevard that you could take a selfie
with for
like otherwise you have to constantly
introduce yourself like hey uh john
walker
i i am captain america so anyway uh i
would say you know like that's that's
all i get it for fighting if you're like
i'm going into a fight i'm gonna suit up
but like when you're just
chilling maybe he could have like a
duster or something over it that he
could pop off if he needs to fight
a mask he had a press conference
announcing who he was
it's not a secret identity yeah well
they ditched like the the
the sunglasses and the hats now so they
don't know what to wear anymore oh
that's right the marvel undercover
uh uniform yeah that's all gone now yeah
yeah uh yeah i i i don't otherwise like
it looks like a captain america
integrated with falcon features costume
it's just that head
thing does it looks like invincible it's
that like
jim lee head cut out thing
with the white shoulders bad not good
don't like it barry jean grey
in the 90s it's very 90s yeah that's
exactly it's that x-men
right there whatever that's called
around the face ahead
well a cowl is like batman's thing i
guess that's what it is yeah yeah
that it just looks very weird with his
with his little ears sticking out he's
gonna catch so many bugs in his teeth
when he's flying around so he's got his
he's got the little ear hole flap it's
like it's just a bad
yeah if anyone needs to have their face
covered it's the guy who's flying around
in a jet pack
like through you know i imagine like
through louisiana perhaps where it's
just
covered in
all right keep going of captain america
one who will call out the problems with
our system if you people have just as
much power as an insane god
then ask them to do better and hope that
it changes anything
you've got to do better senator honestly
the fact that this beach works is the
least realistic part of the mcu
and they share a universe with this guy
[Music]
yeah pause i mean this is just like
marvel's whole
relationship to i guess politics or just
the world at large is like
power i think the way they phrase is
like power just makes people more of
themselves
so it's like we we just have to make
sure that the right people have super
powers
we just have to make sure that the right
guy doesn't get too powerful like
rather than addressing anything you know
more
systematic or like about society they
seem to always be protecting us from
like the one
individual who gets too strong like i
don't know
i i'm obviously not looking to comic
book movies to uh
address the world's ills in like a
thoughtful way but
this one tried to and their answer was
like well
we can leave the system in place that
caused all these problems but
you know if we if the right people are
wearing the the special suits that
everything will be okay
big speech everybody big speech they're
victims of their own success
i think that you know like you can you
could play this game for a few years
of like we're raising these real issues
and like let's really talk about who
should have power should anybody have
this power but the fact of the matter is
they've got to keep making new
superheroes stuff all the time
which is always about heroes built
into the genre of like an individual
changing everything because they use
their power response
right they can't write one where they
conclude that it's wrong for an
individual to have powers and everybody
gives their powers up well in fact they
do
they gave that to zemo the villain right
well that's what i mean like you
couldn't have that be the end of one of
these because then it's like well
okay well sorry eternals but we decided
it's wrong for you to have all this
power
yeah um wow what a uh what a reactionary
genre
this is um i just love to watch them
punch
and shoot laser beams of different
colors at each other you can't have that
uh in bernie sanders america you can't
have these ones
yeah i think at some level it's about
recognizing that it's a power fantasy
while also
trying to at least not just make it that
and also bring up
other interesting things like if you
could service both that oh i did service
again if you could serve both of those
needs i think you're you're doing a good
yeah
but i think there's just two two
instances with like the flag smashers
and then with um
isaiah what's his last bradley bradley
um
where it's like they bring up like with
the flag smashers i feel like that the
show
went out of its way to be like they are
correct
their their cause is just and they are
in the right
but they just but they but they killed
people like that's all they have to
invalidate them is like but they killed
somebody um
without taking on the ideology of it or
like
you know it really engaging with that
and similar with isaiah bradley it's
like
he's been completely wronged and
betrayed by his country but he got a
statue
so it's all good like he got recognized
he got the
him like again like the solutions are
all individual to the problems that are
all
societal but again it's marvel what do
you what do you expect we're not looking
for
uh you know uh i can't think of any
smart books right now
insert smart book right here they're
looking for the credit and i think that
some is due for for raising the issue
they're never going to
come up with a good take on it or
resolve
these questions because they can't they
have to come back to the status quo at
the end yeah so they're they're at least
they're they're
engaging us in these conversations yeah
all right
uh keep going
so enjoy a show that feels like a
stretched out b-tier marvel movie
that annoyingly makes you stay up late
to watch every episode unless you want
it spoiled on twitter
ah dang it in this enjoyable series that
deepens existing characters bring some
big-budget action to the small screen
and add crucial new information to the
marvel universe
the avengers don't get paid how do you
guys make a living
there's a tremendous amount of goodwill
right but you couldn't have been living
off of good will this whole time
we cannot approve you is there some kind
of fun for heroes or
so this is why scarlet witch drives a
bug it's a pause
i mean that's just crazy to me that like
i mean tony stark whatever like he's uh
uh
he's not technically the head of the
avengers right he's just like kind of
providing the facilities
um although he is a mega billionaire he
could kick him some money
pepper potts you think she's like more
thoughtful and like always
crossing that uh tease and dot in the
eyes she might do something
nick fury shield like why isn't shield
paying them anything there's a few
questions here like you do have to take
into account that there was that period
post post-civil war
where sam and bucky specifically were
rogue like obviously they weren't
drawing paychecks when they were hiding
out from the government
like william hurt sees them and is like
arrest those men you know like they're
not gonna get paid
we understand they're not getting paid
during that period it's
before then and then subsequently now
that they came back and saved the world
there was no
like you'd like the department of
defense didn't cut everyone who fought
in that
portals battle like a check you know
like thanks a lot and is falcon like
doing all that
sort of quasi-mercenary work at the
beginning for free
like just to feel alive i feel like you
should get paid assuming at that point
he's getting he's got to be drawing some
kind of
military salary at that point but not
enough to buy lunch like him and what
was it torres were talking and he was
like
i'll get you next time so you know maybe
he's like
who knows what his rent like he could
have other expenses we don't know about
i don't know yeah
but if the snap messed everything up
snap messed up snap so
if you can't monetize being an avenger
do better
get a cameo account uh do
a license your name to a burger chain
like come on
how much would you pay for him to say do
better in a cameo
oh uh anthony mackie as valkyrie
no just falcon oh just falcon just the
falcon i'm in the universe
and yeah falcons on there that's easy an
easy 500.
like if they're they're yeah oh for
falcon to say like happy birthday to
your friend yeah
if mark mcgrath is a hundred falcon is
the falcon is 500. this guy
saved the world like the whole world
yeah
you would that's another thing like so
everybody
knows about like we we've deduced from
all these other
post blip shows and films the whole
world knows everything that happened at
that battle like we've all
heard the updates so everybody who
fought there has been like
those people are all like they have
reality shows they've been on
some talk take selfies like with him
during this show
he's just gonna try to be those they're
like the main heroes but i mean like if
you were like
one of the sorcerers from you know like
that you were just
at that battle you would still be people
would want to talk to you about it like
yeah you know you you may not be like
super famous but you'd be like
like a third stringer from tiger king
level fade
[Laughter]
you know like joel mchale would skype
with you for something like not the main
guy but like the guy who produced the
reality show with the crazy deep voice
like you'd be like that guy
yep yeah uh okay let's keep going
the black falcon was denied a bank loan
i stan sebastian
barron's dance grooves
the carter two a wolf in veep's clothing
goldie spawn just when i thought this
country couldn't get any meaner
you go and do something like this and
totally redeem yourself
power punch girl oh it's those antiva
super soldiers i've been hearing about
and sam's on a boat
stands on about everybody
sam's on the boat sam's on a boat take a
good hard look at sam's sister's parents
boat
sky captain and the shield of tomorrow
we're in a very lonely island kick we
did a hot rod reference they're
practically
begging us to do a stairs montage huh
[Music]
i wish i remembered the uh the music
queue for stairs because people always
ask
like eternal remembrance or something
like that
wait got the music no no no no you can't
stare bait us like that your stairs are
too forced
stairs have to be natural you're doing
the staring thing again
yeah i feel like they were asking for it
they're like come on you know you want
to do the stair
things you didn't stare that much
there's a lot there's a lot of stereo
but there it's like meta staring like
they built they baked it into their
personality
a couple of stair bears over there um
yeah well you know this was um this is
kind of a tough one to do i think
overall just because
uh it was like pretty good and that's
that's that's the honest trailer danger
zone i think
it's like you can't say oh it's the most
incredible thing here's why and you
can't say oh this is garbage here's why
you just
like yeah that's all right i enjoyed
actually
coming off of juan division which
whether you liked it or not
so out there what a big swing that was
so there's a lot to talk about and pick
apart good or bad
whereas this i mean i like this show and
i get what they were doing but it feels
a lot
more like a conventional tv action
adventure series you know like it
it fit into some more obvious buckets
and so there wasn't as much like
what you know whereas one division you
could just go all day it was like yeah
which is having goo battles and robots
and yeah it comes more sitcom goo battle
robots please
take bigger swings it's more fun to
watch and to talk about um
but anything else to say about this
before you go in the deleted scenes
no all right let's watch the deleted
scene it was good i liked it
that shield's the closest thing i've got
left to a family
man and i thought collecting funko pops
was depressing
and i thought wanda conjuring her dead
husband was sad
honestly the fact that this speech works
is the least realistic part of the mcu
and this year's a universe with a cranky
space raccoon
starring hawkeye
birdman bird person
return of the mackie army of one
but one armed man my name is buck and i
like to chalk
bury me with my metal arm don't trust
the z
in a jail in germany every
the queen pin naughty or nice
go go power broker julia fury dreyfus
how much you want to bet he could throw
a football over the mountains american
idiot
look at me i am captain now homelander
icarly horizon anti-hero dawn
holy crap is that mantis
shield of dreams agents of shield
team america world police
recast in america
this serum is how we make change if
you're keeping the super solder serum in
a fanny pack
you deserve to get them smashed
now that sam's got the shield can
someone teach him how to fight his
record ain't so great
[Music]
captain america really should be able to
beat bad truck to leaper
i i got to say i really admire that they
ended this series with no hint about
how he's going to be like we've decided
super soldier serums are bad so he's not
going to take that
so like how is he he's just going to be
a regular man with a jet with a shield
and a jet pack yeah i mean
iron man's a regular man with a suit of
armor that shoots lasers
it's full of missiles
if they were like and and and falcon
gets two guns now be like [ __ ] yeah like
if you get like it's like
you know like if he could do a john woo
thing yeah
then what condensed maybe maybe it's all
special now yeah they can give him a
little upgrade but right
he's gotta be able to like shoot
something at you or like
he's gonna just continue to get there's
levels to this though if there's a mad
space
titan they call you know somebody with
superpowers and if there's like
a a disgruntled uh refugee
who's trying to help people you call
falcon
but even that like he would have lost
like without zemo
and bucky and the dora milaj like he's
only
getting through this one because he's
got a lot of hell
yeah yeah and like it's it's like the
iron man thing we're like what are you
without the suit oh billionaire playboy
philanthropist like what are you without
the suit
i'm kind of broke boat owner
listen a fully recently refurbished book
okay recently
i repainted my parents name on the side
my sister my best friend might make out
that's weird yeah he's got like nothing
i don't date i mean i like sam wilson i
want him to have a fighting
chance out there like let's give them
some guns that's
what i'm saying it's like like they're
not doing the putting like i'm sorry i
really like john bernthal's take on the
punisher i would be like bring him in
but if they're not going to
just just give captain america the
punisher stuff yeah give him all the
punisher stuff he's
got a huge chain gun now make him into a
a bird gun
that shoots birds uh all right let's go
into the uh
into the chat what you guys been saying
about this um what's the ideal show
characters you'd like to see on disney
plus if you had your druthers any
anything on the wish list or
i mean they're they're doing my number
one pick right now which is
moon night i've been long saying moon
knight would be an awesome character and
like oscar isaac's gonna be moonlight so
i'm not
as hyped as he really could possibly be
uh to see that one for sure yeah i think
the dora milaje would be mine
like if you could have one just have
like them going off we've seen that they
can be super spies in different
countries and uh
they have a plethora i wanted to see all
their wigs they have so many wigs that
they use because you can't just walk
around being a bunch of hot black chicks
with bald heads
everyone's going to know you're the dora
melanche now uh so now everybody's got
to have a wig so that's
that's what i want the door milaja wig
special there we go
i also feel like a show like a
succession or billions type show set in
the world of
like evil marvel ceos where like every
ceo
oh hammer super evil and they
all hate each other and they're all
constantly trying to like
one up and steal from each other like
there's a great show to be done yeah you
definitely bring rockwell back his
hammer
and maybe you pretend cory stole didn't
die in ant-man
or bridges like as open dye stained like
i think you could prequel this or
something
i was gonna i i don't think i could beat
that that's fantastic i was gonna say
something like
um uh who's what's mysterio's real name
quentin beck quentin beck uh him and
um trevor slatterly just uh uh like
teaching
teaching an acting school of a villain
impersonation
yes i would definitely like maybe a
berry type thing where they're also
doing crime afterwards like
dude that's so good trevor slattery is
like dude just
just him like in a toast of london type
yes he's
trying to get his next role after the
match is this like oh my god i want to
see that really bad i played the
mandarin
austin powers
all right uh uh stephen h
i have a question loosely tied to falcon
and winter soldier i'm gonna be 30 in a
few years and i want to know how do
people make friends in their 30s
seriously i don't know i don't know get
on a show where you talk about falcon in
the winter soldier for money
and then then all of a sudden now you
have friends every friend i made
in my 30s was from doing this yeah it's
usually through work
or um once you join the uh
the parent club then it's you always
have like it's weird when you're young
it's like oh you two are the same age go
hang out and now it's like oh you two
are dads like go
over there while the kids do the thing
like so do you like sports
it looks wow you guys you get dad friend
dates you get dad-friended
because then you know because the moms
really click and they want to do the
play dates all the time and then right
yeah like yeah so that's those are your
two options it's kind of sad so like
beer
maybe here you do beer she wanted cars
one of those
sure hong kong
you know cars that's what as a young man
i felt like it really hurt my ability to
make dude friends that i didn't know
about sports
cars or computers like those were the
three things i should i needed to know
about yeah you got to fake your way
through it but but and
now i think like marvel has like kind of
broken things wide open and gaming is so
much more popular like you can
bring up some nerd topics and not be
like not get stuffed into a locker which
is still right here
i could have talked about lord of the
rings all day but that was not a thing
when i was a young man you could do that
was not an acceptable that was not in
part of the
cars sports and uh computers world
all right pat mcgonna writes i'm not
super crazy about the sharon power
broker reveal i think the show could
have benefited for more episodes one of
them starring sharon that showed us her
transformation into a villain
yeah you know you know it's they haven't
done a great job when
um people are like oh she must be a
squirrel yeah
that's the only explanation i just think
it was a little
um like it was just it was it was
obvious by like
episode three that she was the power
broker and then before they even like
revealed it they basically revealed that
she would be like oh yeah i know some
people who have some helicopters i'll
take care of it like wait are you what
are you
power broker like i mean there were two
choices it was her or
zemo somehow and they they ruled out
zemo pretty fast
so yeah okay right so it was just like
kind of a nothing like reveal once you
actually got there because they made it
too
easy to figure out and there were no
other candidates who it could have been
yeah no red herrings right um yeah
it just felt like it kind of landed with
a thud it was like okay is there not
another turn coming here
right yeah yeah uh pedro benitez writes
did you notice that bucky straight up
stabs a goon through the heart with a
pole and is still a hero well john
walker is stripped of everything
they all kill yeah i did find it kind of
it's a little incredulous that like
the new captain america is chasing down
like a
wanted terrorist and the fact that he
killed him with his shield
were pretending that wouldn't be cheered
by
50 of america he would be like yeah
that's my captain um i mean it was
we know we know for a fact that would
have because we saw it happen in real
time
what do you mean was it i thought he got
stripped of all of his fans
no in the world of the show i mean real
world fans
are very divided on whether to support
john walker post uh shield murder
right got it yeah i didn't man i gotta
get back on
i don't have to get back on twitter you
know i didn't have to know this i'm just
saying
that's pretty good evidence that that
would have happened if there was a real
captain america as well
yeah um yeah i mean i look i think
they're making a point i think the way
that the show
the the way it was depicted on the
series is that it was
bad not only in like don't kill murder
is always wrong
but the spectacle of it that he didn't
have the self-awareness or composure to
see
the whole world is watching you're being
filmed in front of this huge
we're here to win hearts and minds and
you're still going to
like revenge murder this guy because of
your buddy
and i think that was as much it was the
it was he lost control because captain
america is like a mascot at this point
uh because he's it's both fights but
you're not just a soldier and this is
what steve
implicitly understood that you're you're
a beacon you're you're a symbol
i mean that was his first captain
america ing was just doing you know uh
uso shows and stuff like that so he had
that part down first that's how they
needed to do the training is first you
get to do the song and dance and then if
you're good at that
you get to do the crime fighting yeah
man right maybe why russell just needed
a year or two in the uso
to like get his sea legs under him yeah
uh okay so we still gotta see it as the
uso send them to afghanistan let them
cheer those guys up
uh fair question from tn uh why did zemo
have the last of the flag smashers blown
up in the last episode
uh he has a whole thing about super
soldiers yeah
were they at that point they had all
taken it i guess they had yeah well
that's why
um and let's wipe them up get rid of all
the serum you wipe them all out so
nobody can take a blood sample and
recreate the
the tech yeah uh finally thurban caver
hope i got that right uh can we talk
about how isaiah bradley didn't want his
name out there and sam literally put his
name on a statue in a museum
well yeah there's what you say and then
there's what you mean right like he
but yeah i don't i don't think they
certainly seemed happy once he
saw it like yeah just your work so
yeah i do think you ask first maybe
it's not something you spring on
somebody it's like your own wing of the
museum
that i honestly feel like can you pose
here and i'll just take a bunch of
pictures
i feel like someone from the smithsonian
definitely contacts you if you're alive
and an entire exhibit is being planned
maybe you want to be there at the
opening yeah i feel like somebody some
docent is going to give you a call
can we get a quote something from this
new wing of the smithsonian dedicated to
you specifically
yeah all right and finally um uh evan j
pretzel
uh uh asks if the george costanza
character was
in the mcu uh who would he play well i
let's just say if jason alexander was in
the mcu who should he play that's what i
think
they're asking yes who would jason
alexander play in the
mcu uh i mean that pat and also it's
about to play him in
animation but i feel like the look is
there the live-action modoc would
definitely be a possibility
yeah honestly the thing he could be ben
grimm
oh he'd be a great thing he i want him
as wolverine
because he's got the height finally
that's the height and the fury
yeah i mean he's probably pretty hairy i
think he's a hero suit yeah
we could we could hear him up and post
yeah
that's my pick all right you guys uh
this is super fun
in fact we'll do it again next week uh
when we discuss
um let's see uh well it won't be a
discussion so much as it'll be a test
a test of our strength um that will be
that that's your clue for next week
we'll be back
can't wait for that one uh this has been
fun though thank you danielle thank you
lon
thank you audience we'll see you next
week on australia commentaries bye
[Music]
you